Ever since Frozen came out
and blew kids' (bleep) minds
with its
catchier-than-cooties music,
adults have been speculating
about Queen Elsa's sexuality.
-Of course they have. Uh...
-(laughter)
Of course they have.
I think some adults
have been speculating
really hard.
-(laughter)
-I mean, you know, she's not...
if you look at... you know,
she's not interested
in male suitors,
she sings about keeping
her emotions hidden,
she's super into construction...
-uh...
-(laughter)
So for Frozen 2, fans want
Disney to give Queen Elsa
a lady love to go with it.
Uh, the #GiveElsaAGirlfriend
movement
was started
by a 17-year-old blogger,
and even the voice of Elsa,
Adele Dazeem, chimed in...
-(laughter)
-with her support.
So it looks like Frozen 2
could be a charming lesbian
love story-- though no word
who will voice the couple's
matching French bulldogs.
-(laughter, applause)
-Comedians...
since...
#GiveElsaAGirlfriend
is going so well, uh...
And I think
it's a (bleep) awesome idea
which they should totally do.
Why wouldn't they?
Um, I would like you to come up
with another fictional character
and update them.
Jessica.
Um, #SisterWives2
GastonAndThemTriplets.
-All right, points. All right.
-(cheering, applause)
Rhys Darby.
S...
(laughter)
Someone...
Ha-Hashtag...
(laughter)
#SomeoneCallAnUber
ForBilboBaggins.
(laughter, applause)